[Música]
estimados maestros y maestras en este
vídeo tutorial descubriremos cómo ubicar
contenidos en la malla curricular de
khan academy
empecemos ingresamos a nuestro documento
malla curricular khan academy en él
encontraremos los siguientes encabezados
de celdas
dominio curso tipo url título y
descripción en esta oportunidad
trabajaremos con las celdas curso tipo
título y descripción la celda curso está
referida a los diferentes cursos que
posee cada academia
por ejemplo quinto de primaria geometría
cálculo entre otros la celda tipo se
refiere a la naturaleza del contenido si
es una unidad lección vídeo o ejercicios
de práctica el título es el nombre
exacto del contenido en la plataforma y
finalmente en algunas celdas existe una
breve descripción de cada contenido para
encontrar un contenido o tema debemos
filtrar la celda curso así
identificaremos en qué curso podría
estar este aprendizaje esperado por
ejemplo si queremos encontrar el tema
resolución de ecuaciones cuadráticas
para el tercero de secundaria
clic en el botón filtro de la celda
curso y seleccionar el grado
filtramos la celda tipo y seleccionamos
la unidad
aparecerán cinco unidades con sus
nombres y descripciones identificamos la
unidad con nuestro tema y podemos
agregar en el filtro de la celda
lecciones vídeos o artículos dependiendo
de la necesidad
podremos ver a detalle los contenidos
relacionados al tema buscado por ejemplo
seleccionamos el contenido resolución de
ecuaciones cuadráticas procedemos a
seleccionar el url y lo copiamos en la
barra de direcciones
automáticamente nos llevará a la
ubicación exacta en la plataforma khan
academy dentro de la plataforma y con
nuestro contenido ya ubicado revisaremos
que esta lección posee vídeos artículos
y prácticas elegiremos lo que se ajusta
mejor a nuestra búsqueda
para revisar a fondo el tipo de
problemas o ejercicios que contienen una
práctica daremos clic en el botón
práctica
luego en el botón vamos y empezamos a
practicar
en caso no aparezca el contenido en el
curso podemos encontrarlo utilizando los
filtros en las celdas títulos
recordemos que la familiarización con la
plataforma y la malla curricular khan
academy es un proceso que dependerá del
tiempo que le dediquemos estamos seguros
que lo lograrán rápidamente hasta pronto